c'est un choix c'est un choix qu'il faut
respecter mais je salue aussi le choix
de sylvie goulard que j'ai trouvé tout à
fait honorable et je pense que ça donne
une conséquence qui est logique pour la
suite et c'est un choix c'est un chat
qu'il faut respecter
il a indiqué par ailleurs qu'il
resterait l'un des piliers de cette
majorité et je pense qu'effectivement
c'est une chose importante le modem
reste un pilier de la majorité c'est un
peu aberrant a indiqué qu'il resterait
lui l'un des bruits damage done qu'il
participerait avec le modem à
l'exécution de ce plan de transformation
nous avions porté dans le cadre de la
présidentielle et nous avait rallié
parce qu'ils adhéraient à certaines
valeurs a une vision un projet l'urgence
est aujourd'hui véritablement de
d'engager ses réformes de les mettre en
oeuvre
donc tout l'enjeu est là et il fait
partie de cette majorité il sera il sera
donc aux côtés d' emmanuel macron et ce
ne sera pas l'un des opposants emmanuel
macron comme on a pu le lire absolument
pas positionné d'une de façon à être en
opposition mais bien au contraire a
participé à cette construction de façon
probablement très exigeante et c'est
nécessaire dans une démocratie de
qualité mais dans le cas de la majorité